have you heard about the camel people
are freaking out about the camel in
Pakistan let's take a look at the camel
and then we'll talk about the camel this
is a that's not a real camel don't worry
about that that's not some sort of Star
Wars camel this is a sculpture of a
camel that is gonna cost the US State
Department four hundred thousand dollars
to put at our American Embassy being
built in Islamabad Pakistan and it is
causing an uproar
so let's well let's first go to the
State Department's official document
explaining why this camel is worth four
hundred thousand dollars this artist
product is uniquely qualified public art
which will be presented in the new
embassy should reflect the values of a
predominantly Islamist country that's
according to the State Department okay
that sounds fine to me and just as a
little side note also in the Bible and
in the Quran they both use the metaphor
of a camel passing through the eye of a
needle so there's some religious
background there they're not just
randomly picking something but you know
what the four hundred thousand seems
like a lot apparently we have some
economic problems here and
representative jason Chaffetz he's not
happy about this the American people
have a right to know that their tax
dollars are being spent responsibly
especially for art that the vast
majority of US citizens will never have
the opportunity to view and basically
there's been a whole big Twitter
firestorm as there is about everything
four hundred thousand dollars for a
camel Maz your Persian so you know bit
about this type of area of the world so
take it away well first of all it's kind
of racist I think to have a camel art
piece in Pakistan that's like they'll
like but you know what are you gonna go
to Africa and put a watermelon what do
you what are we doing here people State
Department that's number one and
secondly yeah it's a lot of money I
should I should have gotten into art
yeah just a camel is you know I post a
lot of art events and I don't know if
you guys is comics kept you know what
and the art of it and and the money that
they spend on some of these things and
I'm just sitting there obviously because
you sit there and you go I could have
done that yeah it's just paint on a
canvas
yeah but somehow this person became hot
and that's how much it's worth
worth and I'm sure my people watch me do
stand-up a lot of times they go I can
pay for this yeah yeah yeah well the key
the key of course is to cut your ear off
and then your art value yeah goes way up
Aaron I know you're a you don't like to
spend the money am i right you like
you're a strict conservative when it
comes to Americans kind of money I could
what do you think $400,000 is too much
for this type of thing well you know
it's a camel
I just thought like you know Americans
we pride ourselves on knock-offs
like I feel like he could give me like
10 grand like a building a camel it's
ridiculous $400,000 like if you take the
whole needle out of it it's just like a
stupid ceramic camel it's it's
pretending this is a real camel I mean
that's that's funny we should have
recited pay with real camels you just
can't you just have a few camels when
you arrive at the embassy in Pakistan
and then that's when you really would go
oh I'm in Pakistan Trojan camel are we
gonna hide like CIA CIA spies inside the
camel that late at night we're gonna saw
through it and be like we're gonna get
the bad guys papa I think that's what it
is that maybe that's why they're paying
the money cuz their BF because I think
about hey mr. General Musharraf oh yeah
Pakistan see ya why do you that behavior
he's on trial but they go hey general
so-and-so hey why don't you take this
camera home for a week and he's like oh
of course I would do it secret that's
what it is yeah I might be a Trojan can
like do anything I could think of that
it was four hundred thousand dollars and
then my of course my second thought was
I obviously immediately have to be a
sculptor yeah our morning yeah clearly
yeah
I knew we could bring this to the NSA
somehow is this one of these things
though where the government is always
spending a shitload of money on
everything every embassy everywhere so I
don't even think this has anything to do
with Pakistan and the camel like they're
doing this all the time
so should we ever get upset about this
or is this exactly what we should get
upset about because we're just pissing
money away everywhere as long as we
don't have to mention Benghazi all right
then I think we're fine maybe they're
trying to be like oh well Hillary's
gonna run how do we get out of the
Benghazi let's do four hundred thousand
dollars on the Campbell
everything they said they have they have
some sort of budget set aside all right
I didn't know that's kind of cool yeah
no yeah but well and also it said the
four hundred thousand dollar price tag
is actually a very reduced price for
this sculpture I'm like it's a cam yeah
which I really find that hard to believe
that anyone gave the US government a
reduced price yeah and it has the US
government ever bought anything at a
reduced price you know they do I mean
I've what this guy is saying is that
well that's what that's what blows your
mind you're like wait some some a-hole
paid even more for the camel right but
they're like yeah we got a better
facility came up with the whole needle
metaphor obviously you know any mean
like they're like all right well the
camels are law just a camel but we stick
a needle and then you know bring it from
the Bible and the current like I just
can't like that's culturally what the
needle means I have it written right
here so it's the it's the camel
contemplating needle which is it so the
camels made a fiberglass and it's a play
on the New Testament phrase about the
difficulty that the wealthy have
entering heaven of course the wealthy
are the only ones that can afford a four
hundred thousand dollar camel so it's
the artist wasn't thinking about this
when he like busted out a camel you know
and I mean it's like we then we were
like art let's get the needle and make
this work like he was just like I'm
gonna make a camel there's also funny
what you just said is it's true it's
like it's it's this metaphor of like you
know the poor shall inherit the earth
but only the rich can actually buy the
camel to actually be like in that
interesting we can afford that you guys
can is this a really good argument
though seriously for for lowering taxes
because we just put endless tax money
into everything and then they just piss
it away
so is this could this be something I can
see the Republicans first off cuz it's
Pakistan that scares people but then
also them saying well see were they're
pissing your money away and I think this
is the type of thing that people might
be like yeah we shouldn't be doing this
well the question becomes again what is
it like if they've got a real budget set
aside for if it were like a thing where
like you know you guys know like
colleges which sometimes say we have to
hire performers because we have this
money set aside and we don't use it we
lose it yeah so maybe that's if it's
that situation with the guys like I have
to spend four hundred thousand what can
we find
we got a camel and he's like oh let's
get the camel he doesn't care
they don't care so if this that
situation that then then we we got to go
and go why are we putting such a big
budget on art at the Embassy in Pakistan
other you do want to make the embassy
look nice
can't just be pictures of presidents and
stuff but you know I don't know